match day
it's a major milestone for medical
students
for the past several months students at
unlv's kirk corcorian medical school
have been interviewing at top
residencies in southern nevada and
across the country as finding the right
program is the final critical step in
becoming a practicing physician tas fay
yatate says his acceptance to practice
medicine at cleveland clinic is a dream
my parents had you know a vision you
know for their son to become a physician
and
you know
when you are
in a small town in ethiopia
those things are more like
far from a dream it's not even a dream
the interview process takes about a year
for students to rank their top choices
and for schools to rank them for yatate
he will have to move but in the end he
knows he is making the right choice for
his profession and family i'm not a
traditional student
i have three kids
yeah and going through a medical school
you know while
being a husband and being a father
you know it's more than challenging
robert vargas knows the struggle all too
well first generation i was first to
graduate high school then college and
now medical school so for me it's a
really big deal both my parents came
from mexico with nothing so for me to be
here and be able to have this day with
my family meant a lot vargas will attend
rush university medical center in
chicago but hopes to return to las vegas
latino physicians are less than 10 of
right now physicians practicing so i'm
very excited to be contributing to that
statistic and hopefully come back to las
vegas and continue to give back to such
a great community mary jane balleza live
local now